foreign
in today's video we will be discussing
the Intriguing world of ethical hacking
with the rise of cyber threats and the
increasing need for Global cyber
security ethical hackers have become an
integral part of the modern digital
landscape in this video we will explore
what ethical hackery is why ethical
hacking are in high demand salary Trends
in the field of ethical hacking skills
required for a career in ethical hacking
and tips for starting a successful
career as an ethical hacker at the end
of this video we will be sharing some
useful tips so keep watching till the
end of this video so let's dive in
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question so what is the main goal
of an ethical hacker option A is to hack
into systems and still sensitive
informations option b is to test and
identify vulnerabilities in systems and
networks option C is to create new
security threats and exploits option D
is to cause harm and damage to the
Target organization now you can pause
the video and answer in the comment
section below so let's start with the
first topic that is what is ethical
hacking ethical hacking also known as
Whitehead hacking is the practice of
intentionally probing computer systems
networks or applications to identify
vulnerabilities and weaknesses the main
difference between ethical hackers and
malicious hackers is the intent and
legality of their actions ethical
hackers operate with the permission of
the system honor and their goal is to
identify vulnerabilities before they can
be exploited by malicious hackers they
use their skills and knowledge to help
organization strengthen their cyber
security defenses and protect sensitive
data from unauthorized access as
Reliance on technology and the internet
continues to grow so does the risk of
cyber threats organizations both large
and small are constantly seeking ways to
secure their digital assets and
Safeguard their business operations the
demand has led to a significant need for
skilled ethical hackers who can
proactively identify and fix
vulnerabilities in systems ethical
hackers play a crucial role in helping
organization prevent data breaches
protect customer information maintain
compliance with industry regulations and
Safeguard their reputation with the
increasing awareness of cyber security
threats ethical hackers are in high
demand across various Industries
including Finance Healthcare technology
and government sectors now let's discuss
some salary trends for ethical hackers
the rising demand for cyber security
expertise has led to a significant need
for ethical hackers consequently skilled
Professionals in the field have
experienced favorable salary Trends in
recent years several factors impact the
salaries of ethical hackers including
their experience certifications industry
and region the roles that fall under the
umbrella of an ethical hacker may
include penetration tester penetration
tester also known as spell tester if
you're interested in pursuing your
career as a penetration tester you will
need to develop a strong skill set in
various technical areas including
programming operating system networking
and cyber security principles
pen testers are responsible for
conducting authorized tests on computer
systems networks and applications to
identify vulnerabilities and weaknesses
and provide recommendation for improving
security with an average salary of five
lakhs per year in India and 102 000 in
the United States becoming a penetration
tester can be productive career choice
simply learns professional certificate
program in ethical hacking and
penetration testing is designed to equip
you with the necessary skills to analyze
the threat landscape and develop
strategies to ensure the stability and
security of systems through Hands-On
training in real world cases dual
Masters essential cyber security skills
in just six months you will learn the
advanced cyber security strategies that
will enable you to protect networks and
data from breaches next is vulnerability
accessor this role involves identifying
and accessing potential vulnerabilities
in computer systems networks and
applications using various tools and
techniques to determine the level of
risk associated with those well and
abilities
the average salary of a vulnerability
accessor is 9 lakhs 50 000 in India and
sixty one thousand dollars in the United
States next up we have information
security analyst an information security
analyst is a professional responsible
for protecting an organization
information assets including Data
Systems Network and applications from
potential security breaches and cyber
threats information security analysts
play a critical role in safeguarding
sensitive information and ensuring the
confidentiality integrity and
availability of data the average salary
of an information security analyst is 6
lakhs per year in India and 99 000 per
year in the United States the Caltech
cyber security boot camp is designed to
help you develop the skills needed for
this rule this comprehensive course
curriculum covers defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensics penetration testing
infrastructure design and much more
you'll have the access to labs and
assistive practices that expose you to
several in-demand cyber security tools
allowing you to gain practical hands-on
experience in a supportive learning
environment security analysts this role
involves monitoring and analyzing
computer systems networks and
applications for security incidents and
breaches and taking appropriate actions
to respond to and mitigate these
incidents the average salary of an
information security analyst is 6 lakhs
per year in India and 99 000 per year in
the United States now let's discuss
skills required for a career in ethical
hacking a successful career in ethical
hacking requires strong foundation in
cyber security and a diverse skill set
some of the key skills that aspiring
ethical hackers should possess include
Proficiency in programming language such
as python C plus plus and Java
understanding of networking Concepts
like protocols knowledge of operating
systems and databases expertise in tools
and Technologies used in ethical hacking
such as metasploy via shark and nmap and
familiarity with cyber security
Frameworks and best practices
additionally ethical hackers should have
excellent problem solving skills
critical thinking abilities attention to
detail and the ability to work
independent or as a part of the team
continuous learning and staying updated
with the latest developments in cyber
security is also a crucial for
successful career in ethical hacking now
let's have a look at some tips starting
a career as an ethical hacker can be
exciting and rewarding here are some
tips to help you kick-start your journey
first is demonstrate an ethical hacker
mindset develop curiosity problem
solving and continuous learning mindset
to excel in the field of ethical hacking
second is obtain relevant certifications
certifications like ceh Caltech cyber
security boot camp oscp and advanced
executive programming cyber security
these certifications add credibility and
demonstrate expertise these
certifications will help you in securing
a nice job in the market third is build
practical experience practice ethical
hacking in a controlled environment such
as setting up your own lab or practicing
in CTF competitions to gain hands-on
experience Real World experience will
help you develop practical skills and
insights into different types of systems
networks and applications next is stay
updated with the latest threats and
Technology cyber security landscape is a
constantly evolving and it's a crucial
to stay updated with the latest threats
vulnerabilities and Technologies follow
industry blogs forums and news sources
practice in online communities and
attend conferences and workshops to stay
informed and continuously improve your
skills alright guys with that we have
come to the end of this video If you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up I hope it really helped you all
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here